the jurogan experience that would have
been an interesting fight to see him
versus khabib but the way oliveira
controlled him on the ground
yeah i don't think it would have been
interesting
we wanted to know you know what would
happen because tony's dangerous off
right back
you know like submitted kevin lee right
now he's he's got good jiu jitsu you
know
elbows yeah he's he's tough he's very
very very tough
i think i'm more interested in seeing
oliver fight for the title than anybody
in that division
yeah he's got anything oliveira versus
khabib win
same thing that would have happened to
everybody else i think so i think so
you know it's like khabib's just too
good yeah i i think
you know could be to go to that that
division you know for me
i believe so i believe he's to go to
that division but i don't know what
would happen with oliveira until you see
it
see with oliveira like there are moments
like when cub swanson knocked him out
there's moments and you go back in his
career
and you go oh well this guy's not
the greatest and then you see him in
some fights like the kevin lee fight
we submitted kevin lee right put him out
and then kevin wakes up and thinks
he's still fighting right um submits
tony in a spectacular way
and just just he's so technical yeah
everything's so good he's never out of
position everything's so he doesn't
force anything everything looks [ __ ]
amazing
jiu jitsu looks really good oh amazing
it's amazing and you go man i want to
see him fight for the title i want to
see him fight
dustin i want to see him fight conor i
want to see him fight whoever else is in
that division i don't think
he's going to be a contender anymore
though i think that's it i think that's
it
you know it's like you know i'm sure
he'll make money and
you know he'll probably fight a few more
times if he wants to but it's like
um i i just you know it's like he
you know i think time was probably
taking its toll do you think that's it
or do you think it's just money and
motivation and spending a lot of time
out of the sport
i mean look he's training for floyd so
he's boxing for a long time then he
takes two years off he's fighting khabib
right you know and then he beats cowboy
but just swarmed him you know swarmed
him jumped on him real quick hurt him
quick and
and stopped cowboy was always a slow
starter yeah
you know it's like uh that i i think
it's just you know maybe it's time maybe
it's
maybe it's desire maybe i i don't know i
don't have the answer but
i think the time has come up when it's
easy to say that after
you see the result right yeah but what's
interesting in that fight is there's
moments in that fight where he was
having big success
and he hurt dustin at one point in time
with a big left hand yeah
but that [ __ ] low calf kick yeah that
low calf kick is a beast
yeah that's a it changed it changed the
you know the look on his face yeah i
think i think
me personally i'm a connor fan so
probably i go a little biased on it but
i think it's more so uh
that time you know that time going to uh
boxing and then coming over first fight
back fighting khabib
and then you take time off and then you
come back and then you fight cowboy and
then you
pandemic comes you get a whole another
year off and then you come back and you
fight
dustin poirier let's think about his
last few fights let's think about his
last three losses
you got floyd mayweather right arguably
one of the greatest boxers of all time
if not definitely the best defensive
boxer of all times
right yeah and one of the smartest
boxers of all times
as far as how you did his career and
then you lose the khabib
yeah you say it's the greatest 155 ever
even one around against could be
probably drunk off as whiskey as well
you know
uh then you got the dustin poirier fight
i think he's pretty serious about the
dustin poirier fight
but i think at the same time i think
he's thinking bigger than what he was at
the time i think he's thinking about
boxing pacquiao and doing all these
other things that he goes in there with
uh
my hands are this fantastic and it's
time to show you guys that max holloway
is not the best boxer
he gets chopped at the leg now it's hard
to move yeah it's hard to move you can't
it's hard to defend the takedown it's
hard to grapple it's hard to box it's
hard to do anything
you know me personally i never thought
irishman get knocked out until then
you know so [ __ ] crazy night you know
but yeah i i don't i don't necessarily
think it's over for the guy i just think
the guy has to
not take a rich person's approach i
think he has to take more of approach
than he took back in the day when he was
on welfare
right go out there and get it stop
telling everybody what your training
schedule is going to be and just
[ __ ] do what the [ __ ] gym tells
you to do well he was still
he was pretty [ __ ] rich when he
fought eddie alvarez you know he was
already a multi-millionaire it's not i
don't necessarily think it's a rich
thing
i don't know if that affects him that
much but i do think it's inactivity and
i do think that dustin got a lot better
and dustin's
at 145 dustin was depleted and
diminished at 155 he's [ __ ] huge
he doesn't even look like a 55 or he
looks like a 70. yeah he's
his back is [ __ ] gigantic yeah and
dustin look at dustin's
series of victories look at the people
that he beat beat the [ __ ] out of max
holloway
right that's crazy that was at 155 not
45
right but still yes you still max
hollywood yeah he beat him
he beat him and beat him with what max
holloway is best at which is stand up
and you see what max always did to
calvin cater like right jesus christ max
holloway's
stand-up is outstanding so he beats him
for whatever reason he looked a little
bit slow in that fight
yeah i thought max looked a little bit
off uh when he fought dustin i might be
going away
yeah it's like he's just he was a little
bit slower it's like you know
that last night he looked so fast and
some of the other fights but it's also
alto and he's fighting dustin cause
styles make fights dustin's [ __ ] good
man oh dustin's very good he's [ __ ]
good
and he's not khabib he's not you know
he's not uh
you know he's like he is good but he's
do you think it was another victory
match
you think uh hands down dustin no i
would never say hands down
you never know because conor did have
moments in that fight
he had moments in the first round and
dustin said there was a moment in that
first round he got his bell wrong and he
was in trouble
now imagine if conor connects again
right imagine i mean that's how fights
are connor
weird things happen loose connor connor
who plays touch butt in the park is a
great connor you know
he's moving and he's [ __ ] throwing
those spinning heel kicks and [ __ ]
the thing is though he's heavy on that
front leg
wide karate stance you know he's always
doing this he's always doing this ben
when that leg is available for that low
calf kick that changes everything
changes your whole approach and conor is
also a guy that's never been known
to like switch back and forth he doesn't
like to have
left leg forward it's not that's not a
common thing for him so once his legs
getting chewed up
you know his it's not like he's got that
option like you fight just as good from
orthodox no and it's probably worse from
orthodox now that he all he does is work
on his boxing rights you know it's like
the things that he probably used to do
from a switch dance you know different
kicks different setups
he's probably not there anymore you know
he's probably
really really great fighter from that
one stance but now when you take him
outside of that stance he probably
becomes
you know almost like a c or d great
fighter well they're talking about doing
that fight again
which a lot of people in that division
are pissed because they're like well
what the [ __ ] you guys are tying up
do it championship do it because it's
not really the championship
the championship has not even been
decided whether or not khabib is going
to step down yeah so then there's been
talk well they might do it again but
they'll do it for the belt
no i think charles i think uh charles
and chandler
for uh even an intern belt just some
type of belt
charles and chandler make sense people
probably can get mad about that because
the chandler's
barely coming from bellator over to ufc
but come on dude he just knocked out dan
hooker
yeah he didn't take him down and smash
smashed him which we all thought he was
gonna do he
knocked him out one punch with that left
hook that we talked about right
yeah yeah beautiful long one too long
left hook
yeah touched him to the body with the
right hand and left hooked him the the
bronx guy
you know the charles you know he's he's
been doing great he deserves to fight
for a belt
so him and uh you know
mr bellator fighting for a belt i think
it sounds good and i think
how many people don't even fight for the
battle well does that make sense
he's trying to make money right now he's
not he's like his money lost at khabib
so
yeah you know yeah he lost the khabib
you know he almost submitted he almost
admitted khabib you know he could be
even a really tight guillotine yeah
you know i mean he took him into deep
water yeah i mean i'm pretty sure it
could be probably farted two times in
that guillotine
you know what i mean it's like yeah when
you get choked real hard it's like
you know you pass over and you're good
to go you know
do you like what do you do with justin
gaijin because justin
just got it he got subbed his
performance i like justin gaichi but his
performance against khabib was
was [ __ ] embarrassing yeah
derrick brunson that's a problem don't
run from somebody just because they're
good
but he's gotta keep a way to land those
leg kicks yeah he was hurting him
what's wrong with the jab nobody throws
jabs don't you remember that
i want you to remember that okay you
said that thank you
[ __ ] i set myself up but yeah i i
i from everything i've seen from justin
gaiji and then that fight i was like oh
[ __ ] that dude
you didn't like it i lost money on that
[ __ ] hell yeah what do you think about
gaichi versus chandler that's a good
fight
that'd be fun right that's good yeah
that's a good fight
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience